well we're getting dangerously close if
not already moving beyond the Battle of
Fort Sumter I bring you now to Wikipedia
a very simple short explanation of the
Battle of Fort Sumter this is just
talking about you know the Civil War
they say on March 4th 1861 Abraham
Lincoln was sworn in as president in his
inaugural address he argued the
Constitution was a more that the
Constitution was a more perfect union
than the earlier Articles of
Confederation yada yada he talked about
all this great stuff the South sent
delegations to Washington offered to pay
for federal properties and entered into
a peace treaty with the US this is after
this is I believe seven states seceded I
don't want to read through the whole
thing though but seven states whatever
let's talk about four it's something her
specifically I'm not here to do a Civil
War history lesson just this particular
point right they say Fort Sumter is
located in the middle of the harbor of
SART I'm sorry of Charleston South
Carolina it's garrison had recently
moved there to avoid incidents with
local militias in the streets of the
city Lincoln told its commander Major
Anderson to hold on until fired upon
Confederate President Jefferson Davis
ordered the surrender of the fort
Anderson gave a conditional replied the
Confederate government rejected and
Davis ordered general PGT Beauregard to
attack the fort before a relief
expedition could arrive he bombarded
Fort Sumter on April 12th through 13th
forcing its capitulation the attack on
Fort Sumter rallied the north to the
defense of American nationalism
interesting historian Allan Nevins
underscored the significance of the
event the thunderclap of Sumter produced
a startling crystallization of northern
sentiment anger swept the land from
every side came news of mass meetings
speeches resolutions tenders of business
support the muster of companies and
regiments the determined action of
governors and legislature union leaders
incorrectly assumed that only a minority
of southerners were in favor of
secession and that there were large
numbers of southern unionists that could
be counted on had northerners realized
that most southerners favored secession
they might have hesitated at attempting
the enormous task of conquering a united
self Lincoln called an all on all the
states to send forces to recapture the
Ford and other federal properties the
scale of the rebellion appeared to be
small so we called for only seven
5,000 volunteers for 90 days the
governor of Massachusetts had state
regiments on trains headed south the
next day in western Missouri local
secessionist seized Liberty Arsenal and
May 3rd 1861 Lincoln called for an
additional 42 thousand volunteers for a
period of three years four states in the
middle of the upper self had repeatedly
rejected Confederate overtures
but now Virginia Tennessee Arkansas and
North Carolina refused to send forces
against their neighbors declared their
secession and joined the Confederacy to
reward Virginia the Confederate capital
was moved to Richmond a lot of people
don't know this that the original
secession wasn't the entirety of the
Confederacy it was only after Lincoln
was like I'm taking Fort Sumter against
their will that everyone else was like
dude this is nuts
I didn't know that yeah there it is
right there Wikipedia son Virginia
Tennessee Arkansas North Carolina we're
like we're not gonna do this we're out
we're joining them this is getting nuts
I mean from a practical standpoint the
their their argument was based on you
know you can't come into our state when
we've seceded from the Union and then
take this fort I you know it's familiar
well the thing about the look yeah so
right now Trump is saying the the Union
whatever whatever we end up calling it
has a right to you know enforce the laws
of the United so America we are a united
country for these individual states to
be saying no I don't know what's gonna
look like it's not gonna look like the
North versus the south but what happens
when Illinois Pennsylvania Georgia
Oregon Washington California form a
coalition what happens when they form
the National popular vote coalition a
bunch of states that are all
left-leaning that demand the vote goes
to the popular vote winner what happens
if come November Trump wins a narrow
electoral college victory somehow Joe
Biden wins the popular vote and the
coalition of states in the popular vote
side reject federal authority outright
and say buh-bye and then Trump says we
comin in we're gonna shut you down I
don't know it sounds viable though it
sounds like that could happen maybe
maybe not I don't know but but what I
will point out there's a few interesting
things in this article when they
mentioned Allan Nevins the historian he
talked about anger sweeping the land
from every side came news of mass
meetings speeches resolutions tenders of
business support the muster of companies
and regiments the determined action of
governors and legislators except all
that is happening for the left not the
right
the right is doing nothing I just sit
there listen right now it's the federal
government fighting civilians and state
governments know that I keep saying this
it's like the the people on the right
are there they've got lives that they're
working on their properties they're at a
certain job sure but at a certain point
man yeah yes sure yeah okay but you know
we can't discount that that that whole
the majority of Americans that aren't
standing out in Portland they had 2,000
people okay 2,000 people that are out
there and you have someone who's only
made a meme photo of like the culture
war belligerence and it was all of the
brands and government agencies of the
left mm-hmm the right had like nothing
how many companies have overtly come out
and said no to intersectional ISM I mean
you know Red Bull yeah there you go but
it's it's the it's the start I mean Koya
I mean we we are we're seeing well
there's a there's a shift that's
happening right now where people are
like you know what we we have had enough
we are over this like we're we are
realizes maybe they're watching you
maybe they're here and you say we enough
is enough you know but I mean we're
seeing it I I'm certainly seeing you
know more and more people are starting
to stand up and be like this is
ridiculous defend defend the police you
know we got a good man we got to stand
up I I tweeted that somebody I met at a
black lives matter protest in 2014 is
now 100% Trump train posting memes
proposing all this Trump jr. stuff and
when I tweeted about it the left just
refuses to accept it right of course
that could be their downfall and that's
the other point I wanna bring up right
here they say that had northerners
realized that most southerners had
favored secession they might have
hesitated at attempting the enormous
task of conquering yet itself it could
be that these far leftists had that had
they known just how large the silent
majority was they would have been
reticent to actually try and stay
is kind of insurrection against a United
aunty SJW front yeah but maybe not I
mean the North won in that regard you
know the Democrats lost last time
maybe they'll lose again you know those
perennial losers the Republicans will
keep winning all the civil conflict yeah
I mean it's not even just Republicans I
mean I might head up was talking to a
friend of mine today and he was like
talking about the Democrats and he was
saying we we as in like him and the
Democrats and I'm like what you think
that I'm a Republican now just because
I'm voting Trump like it's like I don't
agree with all the things that they're
talking about I don't agree with all the
things the Democrats are talking about
there's such thing as being in the
middle and looking at both sides
critically thinking about it talking
about what each side is doing and if I'm
gonna choose between Biden and Trump I'm
absolutely gonna vote Trump period take
a look at this article there you go
Democrats are replacing Republicans as
the preferred party of the very wealthy
so when your friend is this is from June
3rd 2016 yeah wonder why Trump won so
when your friend says we referring to
the Democrats what does he think they're
doing for him I asked him that we had a
long conversation
I kept site I kept saying like what is
it about my politics that you don't
agree with because I'm pretty sure we
agree with a lot of things you know and
every it's funny we had a long hour-long
conversation and every single thing I
was talking about he was like yeah
everything sing at every single thing he
was talking about I was like yeah it
turns out we actually agreed on most
things and as always it turns out he
didn't know a lot of the the things that
Trump was doing exactly and is gonna
turn that that's what a attention well
most people aren't I certain I can only
really speak for myself I had no idea I
had no idea but now I now I have very
much a clue of what's going on it's
crazier than ever man I agree it is I
agree as time goes on and the sheer
desperation of the Democratic Party
you know just become it becomes more and
more visible put it that way absolutely
and now with like there's just
they demanded mail-in voting and now
mail-in voting is broken yep
why because they need to pull all the
stops to get him out of it would rather
destroy this country then yeah
absolutely
they they can't have him continue doing
what he's doing because he wants to make
America strong and bring up
manufacturing back and make it so that
people can't go overseas to just make
crazy profit and and have all the people
buying products and that money is
leaving the country instead of staying
in the country have they been right
about anything no not that I know of
Russia gate someone someone tell me
something that they've been right on I
happily no no to be fair you know in the
and I think in the sense we're talking
there's going to be small things they
probably got right sure yeah I can't
name anything offhand in terms of all
these big major stories we can say
Russia gate was a huge waste of
everybody's time
yeah just dramatically wrong for three
plus years well in it fueled the whole
orange man bad thing that has but
they've been using as a fuel to like but
look at these vagotomy
dude I'll be honest like I I didn't like
him but then I like looked in it and I'm
like had it questioned myself like why
don't I like him I'm watching his
speeches I'm hearing what he's saying
now I'm looking at his policies based on
what he's telling me then I'm looking at
the media and hearing what they're
saying based on what he's saying and it
none of it makes any sense the one thing
that does make sense to me are the
policies he's putting forward and I'm
like I can get behind all that you know
what you know you know man um if you try
to force me to do something I'll do the
opposite I don't like being forced to do
anything yeah I agree with you
completely I what you know I don't know
if abstinence is the right word but it's
kind of like if somebody came up to me
and said I demand you do this or else
I'd be like I'm gonna do the exact
opposite yeah you know like I would
rather go down in flames jamming you up
then living on my knees helping you do
anything I'm curious how would you feel
if Joe Biden said to you look fat if you
don't know if you're voting for me you
aren't Korean how would that make you
feel just not good I get it yeah
no I died cuss him out
me to helm the go shove it I and you
know what props to that guy that was
doing Charlemagne was doing that show
them props for him keeping his cool cuz
man that would piss me off and and his
follow-up to that was insanely racist he
said that Charlemagne was being a wise
guy and I was like excuse me the dude
ask you a legitimate question right
exactly
he said what are you gonna do for my
community then when you said that stupid
line about you ain't black Charlamagne
tha God was like no no I'm asking you a
real question man you won though you
want the votes then he has the nerve to
run another showing as well you know he
was being a wise guy so it's terrible
you know I don't I don't care about this
guy this guy is a lunatic who doesn't
you can't think or talk straight and
they don't care and they know it yeah
they're just jamming and just and
shaking and damaging everything yeah
unless they clearly don't care about
those communities at all this is why I
said this is why I asked have they been
right about anything Russia gate cost us
years and Trump still managed to make a
good economy those hardest years waste
of money just fake news non-stop for
years making everyone go nuts
Ukraine gate was fake The Whistleblower
thing was fake they didn't it turns out
now you know the the the testimony of
the Russia Gate stuffs being released
these guys were lying the entire time
yep then they do impeachment wasting
everybody's time the Democrats very
early on were completely wrong about
kovat yeah
Trump was correct early on and then they
both don't desert they both deserve some
credit for flubs okay Donald Trump what
wasn't fast enough on certain issues
that's fine
okay I think I think we can say nobody
nobody wins that one but but to act like
they did a good job is insane and to act
like that Trump didn't want the best for
the American people his own grandfather
died to the last pandemic in this
country justice go ahead Jesse Smollett
wrong fake yep Covington's story wrong
fake then they demanded mail-in voting
and when Trump said it's gonna be bad
and the Republicans were like we're not
ready for this
they went Trump is so dumb he voted by
mail mail and voting's been around
forever and you you actually listened to
these people and I'll say something very
simple to you ah yes you are correct
mail-in voting has been around forever
but mass mail and voting is something we
don't do we are not prepared for and now
we're getting from the New York Times
story after so
sixty-five thousand plus votes are not
counted because of postal service errors
yep California just didn't count a
hundred thousand right and in many
places it's young voters and under
marginalized communities that don't know
how to vote who are getting disqualified
because there's no one there to help
them and that's what the Democrats
wanted so they have been making a mess
of everything non-stop yep blaming in
time so you know you know what you know
it man okay I won't attribute malice
that which can be explained by
incompetence that means we've got the
Three Stooges for the Democrats running
around going well darn yeah yeah I mean
there's only there's only so long that
that that saying goes before you go okay
it's malice now okay you know what
that's enough incompetence it's malice
there you there has to be a line that
you're like you know what we finally
crossed it clearly something's going on
that that shouldn't be going on thanks
for checking out this clip from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show live
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if you
want to catch the full show tune in to
this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you